lock your pin to this video playing elow
2013 does he have this rating I don't
know it's got no name let's go to the
Kings Indian oh no playing a modern
defense now don't i don't really don't
really believe in this this type of
opening i have played this myself when I
was some much younger black but does not
does not lead to that good play you
simply m you simply have problems in the
center than the long run you can play
the six but this is just not a great
structure you know the only way to to
get some counter play and the structure
let's see should I play f4 and then take
ya one way to go can you go to g4
mm-hmm yeah maybe this wasn't too
precise okay wow I thought Bishop takes
wasn't it wasn't so bad mm yeah taking
what the point is very surprising
killing your own bishop hmm okay one
problem is the d5 square I can probably
manage Bishop F 395 at some point and
very important is the f4 pond I have
control over 85 so that is not as some
bad piece okay mother this is now gets
ugly be six young well okay c5 was an
idea i understand that i know i don't
think i need to cover be to throttling
on c7 save a temple
yeah but I have Bishop f2 and now he's
having this overloaded it was
strategically very difficult though
black resigned yeah this is I think
taken with the pawn is really a big
mistake you must take with the bishop
and then blackest is ok I guess I
probably did something wrong I mean
after that black has an okay position I
still rather be white but still it
should be okay I have comparable ideas
to the game like night here to d5 bishop
at three but this is an active piece now
and after the porn capture this is a
week and see a this week so this is this
feels very like very simple play now
like it's blacks almost busted here
computers on plus tube already yeah the
strategical advantages are very very
high here very big yeah almost
unplayable this is weak and PP doesn't
really have a great move this is the
comp suggestion can even play here to
probably just get the porn well ugly
thanks for watching